this is the production of Cornell
University
so as was mentioned I just recently
started my assistant professorship at
Penn State University and so all this
work that I'll be telling you about is
all the work that I did previously at
the University of Arizona but we'll be
continuing on in my new position and so
we'll be looking at the causes and
consequences of antagonism among
different isolates four different
strains of pseudomonas syringae and
we'll be focusing in on this molecule
healer hear that i'll be telling you
more about or the SEC structure I should
say so first there's a lot of people
that have been interested in this field
of thinking about plant associated
microbial communities and the different
factors that influence these communities
of course views have a number of effects
for plant health and production this
crowd is I don't need to explain that in
detail for this crowd but there's been a
number of things that have been you know
over the past decades that have been
understood in terms of pi hosts being
important which organ you look at or
even more recently was compliant
genotype is in terms of determining what
the microbiome for the plant is going to
be as well there's also been as
understanding that the other microbial
members that are present are helping
structure the community as well this is
really where my interest focuses is
understanding the interactions that are
occurring between these resident
microbes within the plant environment so
my research questions really focus on
how do you microbial interactions affect
the ecology and evolution of these fine
associated microbes what are the genetic
basis of these interactions this is
where I focus or where I come from from
a very molecular genetic and molecular
biology background so I'm always
interested in what the mechanisms of
these interactions are how these
interactions are then going to influence
downstream five microbe interactions and
then finally as was alluded to how can
we exploit these interactions for say
pathogen control or stimulating
communities that are going to improve my
health and productivity but for the
purpose of today we're just going to
focus on these two areas here so a lot
of people here are very familiar with
Sigmund stringy I won't belabor it too
much but it's a ubiquitous final
pathogen there's over 50 or 60 different
paths noise now that has been described
and so as a species again fact a wide
range of host crops or host species so
when we think about the phases of
bacterial host interactions there's a
lot of work a lot of great work done
here thinking about the pathogen once it
gets inside and sort of the interaction
between the microbe and its host plant
at the genetic level I come from the
background coming out of Steve's lab at
Berkeley where the focus was a little
bit more on understanding the microbes
as their existing on the leaf surface
and so what are the stressors that they
encounter there and how do they survive
there so that they can build up a
sizable enough population that ingress
into the plant host is a lightweight
occurrence and so we know that things
like acquiring nutrients evading
defecation stress or desiccation
tolerance as well as tolerating UV
exposure are all major factors for
bacteria living in this environment that
they have to tolerate so when we think
about the microbes in on the leaf
surface one thing is that we need to
realize or keep in mind is that they're
found in aggregate so they're not spread
evenly across the leaf surface and that
these aggregates tend to associate with
particular anatomical features so the
base of glandular trichomes or in the
intracellular grooves and so that's what
I'm showing here with this glandular try
come here we have a large aggregate of
bacterial cells you're forming and
there's a number of reasons why we think
these aggregates form at these locations
and one of them is that the data seems
to suggest that these are really where
you're getting leakage of water and
nutrients from the week interior onto
the exterior and so this is where the
bacteria are actually going to make a
living and so if we think about these
microbes fighting for finite resources
of course there's going to be
competition there's only so much space
and only so much nutrients that are
leaking out so we think about we know
that there is a number of different
species and within a species there's a
great especially for stringy there can
be
great diversity of different strains
that are inhabiting the same environment
so we think about them potentially
interfering with each other's ability to
compete this could either be to
requiring resources more effectively
than the other member but the thing that
I'll be telling you about today focuses
more specifically on antimicrobial
mediated antagonism and specifically
this class of compounds here referred to
collectively as bacteriocins and this is
a large group of different proteinaceous
compounds and you can think of them
essentially as highly specific
antibiotics so with an antibiotic you
would expect that most all members
within a given species if that species
are sensitive to the antibiotic most all
the members will be sensitive to that
same antibiotic except for those that
have a specific resistance cassette for
these systems it's quite the opposite
just because one string of species is
sensitive to a given bacteria so there's
no reason to expect another strain will
also be sensitive and so there's a high
degree of specificity again and they're
also protein-based so this is another
thing that separates them from a
traditional antibiotics and this is a
little bit of a renaissance within this
field I would say there's a number of
groups that have started to become
interested it's not just within cerini
but with another student known as other
environmental pseudomonads as well but
if you look at the literature from about
the mid 60s through the early 70s there
was also a number of groups at this time
looking at it and the diverse group in
particular one that I'm just
highlighting here these bacteriocins but
at this point all of the tools are all
the questions that were being asked
we're using bacteriocins basically for
species delimitation as well as
epidemiological markers and of course
are the tools available at that time
didn't allow for really in detail
analysis of the particular bacteria is
being produced so the field shifted away
from this into a number of different
angles and so this is sort of something
that again had been looked at but
there's still a number of very relevant
and important questions that need to be
asked and so the three things that I'll
tell you about today is the gym
a bacteriocin production this is all
again within soon on stringy as well as
some of the work on the genetics of
sensitivity and then some of our hint as
to what potential ecological role these
actually may be playing in the
environment so first off to screen for
bacteriocins it's very straightforward
you just have your your strain growing
up in the broth culture you add some
chemical inductance or you just let it
grow long enough and eventually the
cells in there will lice and release the
killing agent in this case of bacteria
sand into the supernatant filter
sterilized pellet cells and then just
you have the sterile supernatant here
and then you spot this onto a lawn
recipient bacteria and so in this case
the donor strain is going to be one
Pseudomonas string eat in this case
probably path of our and then all these
recipients trains again I think the
different strengths stringy so as you
would expect if you just had a medium
and you spotted on sterile media you
won't get any inhibition of growth but
with the supernatant containing the
bacteriocin and a strain that sense that
you'll get a very defined killings off
and as I mentioned you can have the same
supernatant on an alternative string and
you won't see any additional until ever
so we're very specific so these were the
original 18 strains that I selected for
screening and this represents a fair
amount of the diversity within
Pseudomonas stringy although there's
many more environmental strings and
other Tyler groups now that we know
about in solicit showing just the
cladogram of their relationship and all
of these columns are going to indicate
where the activity is coming from and so
I'm spotting all by all all of the
columns are going to indicate where the
activity is going so these are the
producers and these are the sensitive
strains being tested so where there's a
wide box that will indicate killing
activity on black box will indicate no
activity so the first thing you can see
is that there's a quite a diversity of
killing activity among these different
strains in fact you can see that there's
certain pattern
like t1 and lacquer man's 106 up here
they have very similar killing spectra
and it's also very similar to sit seven
or pga down here and so these are not
very closely related but they seem to
have the same killing specter or very
closely related killing spectrum so this
indicates there's a high amount of
genetic diversity underlying with
genotype within their species so as I
mentioned my interest really stems from
the genetics underline this phenotype
and so for that i went in and focused on
b7 288 been a workhorse in the field for
some time and this is also holdover from
my graduate work that I'm most
comfortable with this particular string
and trying to understand what were the
genetic determinants for its killing
activity so we have a complete genome
there's online databases that you can
feed the genome into and it'll predict
most all the bacteria so that are
encoded within a given genome and so it
predicted these two different
bacteriocins here and these are just
their locust tags and they're related to
ecoli bacteria social are single
proteins and i have a characteristic
catalytic domain and the characteristic
immunity protein that protects the
producing strain so that are very easy
to predict however when i deleted both
of these individually there was no loss
of killing activity and then when I
stacked the deletion there was still no
offline activities misled the idea that
of course there's some other source for
this killing activity and where's of
that so doing some literature searches
as well as some more genome gazing I
happened upon another area and this was
just a regulator that I thought might be
involved and on the whole deleting it I
called a joint activity so what is this
dune well it is located in this region
that was originally described to the
prophage region so the regulator I
deleted or the pair of regulators are
here and then downstream was this
annotated prophage
actually conserved throughout sumon
stringy and it's within this larger or
flanked by these two but I uses mile
markers trippy and trip Jesus basically
interrupted the tryptophan biosynthetic
operon and so this regulator led to loss
of killing activity and so I had a sense
maybe this prophage region was involved
in the killing activity but of course
this could be regulating many things
just to remind ourselves when we're
talking about pro pages most people are
very familiar with this but just to make
sure with the bacteriophage for
temperate bacteriophages we think of
them as having these two different life
cycles the characteristic one where it
injects its oh so or sorry its genome
into the host cell the genomes
replicated the genes are expressed this
leads to formation of new variants that
are then released into the environment
we have virus replication there's the
alternative pathway where once the
genomes injected into the host cell it
actually integrates into the host cell
genome and is maintained there in a
quiescent state and so it's replicating
as long as the cells replicating and at
some point this will become induced to
exit back out and go back into the lytic
replication cycle and so this region
that I found looked like an integrated
bacteriophage so as I said deleted the
regulator and we're anticipating that
it's regulating the rest of the genes
for the bacteriophage and then
complement it i also deleted the genes
that made up the tail structure of the
bacteriophage as well as the receptor
binding proteins and these are the parts
of the bacteriophage that are critical
for interacting with its host cell and
then that could be complemented as well
so deletion of the regulator killing
goes away it's complemented deletion of
the tail genes also abolished as the
killing activity this was a large region
that I didn't want to it was about 10 KB
and I didn't want to take the time to
complement because it would have been a
little bit of a hassle so then just
focusing on the receptor binding
proteins I also lose connectivity and
this is complement and so we can say now
that this
predicted prophage encodes a
bacteriophage drive bacteriocin or what
we commonly just referred to as a tale
of sin and so as Melanie had actually
alluded to her work looking at the pious
ins of pseudomonas aeruginosa these have
been studied for a long time three four
decades if not longer actually and since
the besom trade AGM and there's been a
number of stringy genomes that had been
sequenced and we had the original search
you know they've been number of genomic
comparisons that there had never been a
description of a tailless and encoded
within the genomes of the strains that I
was looking at it led to this question
why is that if we've had this
information and we would think that if
it was just one co-option of one
bacteria page for this that we would
have seen it in the genome that wasn't
the case so again the question is are
these derived from the same progenitor
so if we look at the genomic sequence
they're actually located in the same
area so here in original just again the
mile markers trippy and rip gee it's the
same region for pseudomonas syringae but
when we compared the nucleotides
identity across this region we can see
that the conserved bacterial genes
indeed are conserved right we think
they're vertically inherited but there
is no nucleotide or protein sequence
similarity at all between these two
tables of regions so it seems the answer
seems to be that no these are derived
from independent progenitors but just to
wrap that up we did some phylogenetic
inference comparing these two tails and
to their progenitor bacteriophages to
see if they were clustering similar to
each other or at with different
bacterial pages indeed that's what we
saw so here we see pseudomonas ringing
and all the I slips up here our most
closely related to either phage new or
page SSB for this particular protein
whereas pseudomonas aeruginosa is
clustering with HP too and we see this
for all three of the genes that we
actually had a reasonable amount of
alignment that we could rely on most of
the other genes that are present
you can't align them so you can't do
these sorts of analyses okay so then the
conclusion is these are in fact drived
independently of each other they don't
have really any nucleotide approaching
sequence identity to speak of their
clustering with distance actuary pages
these bacteria pages are related to each
other but people who work on
bacteriophages know them to be very
distinct from each other and so this
means that there's been multiple levels
of convergence that's occurred first we
have the synthetic conversion so that
both of these Taylor sins are ending up
in the same genomic region in these two
hosts we also have the phenotypic
convergence where we're going from a
bacteriophage to a bacterial Center to
at a lesson and so this would also
suggest that there's going to be some
molecular convergence as well what do I
mean by that so just very grossly
looking at this structure for the maya
verde so these are tail bacteriophages
that have a double-stranded DNA genome
you have the header the capsid
associated or attached to that as the
tail and then at the distal end again
are the tail fibers or the receptor
binding proteins and so this is what it
would look like with tem when we compare
the genes that are conserved here within
the tailless in region 4 this is B 728 a
back to SF b or page me and just focus
on page me up here you can see this only
the genes corresponding to the tail
region are retained so all the genes
necessary for regulation capsid
morphogenesis and such have been lost
from the page we need genome in this
talisman region and this was something
that had already been understood to
occur with the tailless and for
pseudomonas aeruginosa as well and so we
can see that we have the similar loss of
genes between these two systems so then
you go from bona fide bacteriophage to
this structure here where again now you
can see just the tail there's no head or
capsid associated with this structure
so how we think these are working
borrowing from the literature for
pseudomonas aeruginosa if you look at
the outer membrane right for gram
negative bacteria the tail fibers
interact with a cell surface receptor on
the outer membrane the tail contracts
drives this core structure through the
outer membrane into the inner membrane
and this is going to deliver the phage
genome to the host so if you don't have
a genome to deliver though and we think
there's other adaptations as well as big
part of this is you don't have a genome
to deliver so you're basically an open
end up here and it still is going to
contract it's going to interact or drive
the core through the outer membrane and
into the inner membrane but at this
point it's going to lead to
depolarization rather than sage delivery
or sorry genome delivery so I was we can
imagine with these tail fibers since
it's known from the work with bacterial
pages that these are important for
interacting with the host cells this is
a great target then for starting to
think about the specificity between a
given to a lesson and the cells that are
for the strings that are targeted by
that Taylor femme and so if we look at
this region across the number of
different strains we can see that the
receptor binding protein itself tends to
be the most divergent and so this region
here sequence similarity would extend
for about 10 or 15 kilobases upstream
which are all the core components of the
tail offense but with the receptor
binding protein and its associated
chaperone there seems to be a lot of
evolution recombination that's occurring
in this region so can we engineer
retargeting in this way and the answer
is yes so for pj a path of our japonica
it is not natively able to kill pass
parked in india or path of our glycemia
as i'm showing up here however if i just
take those two genes the receptor
binding protein and we associate the
chaperone from be 720 and express it and
japonica without anything else i can now
retarget it to kill these two strings
because of these
to relate natively kills those teacher
and so I've done this for a number of
different strains and all of this
activity is transferable from pj i've
done with be seven tre day as well and
these other strains so basically
everywhere where I look I don't
anticipate all of this activities
derived from the tail so that it seems
like that's the majority of the killing
activity because I have some evidence
and I'll show you that in a second of
what some of these other bacteriocins
maybe do and again these killing spectra
are readily modifiable ok so now
shifting to we have essentially the key
in this scenario right so what's the
lock what is it about the host cell
that's also determining the specificity
we focused in early on a little
polysaccharides we had a couple of
reasons for doing that's one all of the
bacteriophages that these tail essence
are related to they all target LPS and
most people are familiar with this with
the major component of the gram-negative
outer membrane where you've got this
lipid portion here that's embedded in
the outer membrane another portion of
the core oligosaccharide that does vary
a little bit but tends not to very very
significantly among strains and then the
highly divergent Oh specific or the
o-antigen component it's highly variable
among strange even within a species so
as I mentioned it was this is a known
receptor for back the bacteria pages
that the tail of sins are derived from
but also as you would expect for the
students original site a listen as well
so we received a number of streams from
that Templeton's group and New Zealand
where he had characterized LPS mutants
and so these are all transposon
insertion mutants so I'm showing up here
at the top we have wild-type LPS this is
the wild-type strain and then these are
two strains that have a transposon
insertion but it's not associated with
LPS
so we can see that the killing activity
for this strain is tailless and arrived
because the structural mutant and the
receptor binding protein needles they
lose all the account activity we still
have killing for these LPS mutants down
here for the wild husband we would
expect that if the LPS is the receptor
that we wouldn't have seen any join
activities however there's two things
that you can see right away first is
that these killings owns are
phenotypically distinguishable from you
so these have a very sharp edge which is
characteristic of the tails and killing
because it's a big bulky structure they
cannot diffuse efficiently truth yoga
whereas for other compounds like smaller
single protein bacteriocins they're much
smaller and so they can deceased diffuse
through the auger matrix so you can get
the diffused killing zone here but the
other bit of evidence to show that it's
clearly not fit a lesson is in the
tailless and deletion mutants we still
had the same killing activity recovered
and so this indicates that there's
actually some other source of the
killing and so as I had shown before the
deletion of this particular bacteriocin
it doesn't affect the killing of the
wild-type strings with wild-type LPS
deletion compliments and then the mock
compliment however now with these LPS
means you can see that by deleting this
alternative bacteriocin all the killing
activities abolished in this is all
complement able as well so we have a
genetic distinction here between the
killing activities but we can also
distinguish them physically as well so
by doing a step of paid precipitation
it's just a simple method where you can
separate bulky high molecular weight
molecules from smaller molecule early
molecules this is very efficient for
recovering and it was developed as a
technique in the bacteriophage field you
can see that we can recover all of the
tails and mediated killing activity the
two mutants complimented mutant and then
a mox compliment but all the killing
activity against the LTS weakness was
completely lost and not be comfortable
and so this is really interesting and is
something actually that to my knowledge
has not been reported on within the
bacteriocin field
that's that gaining resistance to one
tailless and led to sensitivity of the
other Taylor sense so it's not just not
only is there redundancy here but it's
conditional redundancy it's not but
they're both killing at the same time
but one has to be sent or sorry the
string has to become resistant to one to
become sensitive to the other so
additionally we recovered a number of
streams that were resistant de novo
resistance to the talisman and so
working here with the green bean
pathogen half of our physio licola as
well as the soy pathogen path of our
glycaemia i just essentially exposed
these cultures to the b7 trade a
tailless n selected for resisting colony
confirm their resistance in sequence
their genome and as we would expect most
of the genes that we recovered this is
just a small subset of the mutants that
I've sequence they all map back to genes
glycosyltransferases in particular in
these are well known to be involved in
LPS biosynthesis and they're closely
related to those that have been
described in e.coli and so the question
that I had coming out of this thinking
about how these interactions in between
these microbes in the environment we
expect that there will be selection for
resistance that will be imposed within
the environment and so if the strain
does become an assistant to a given
bacteria sending in this case sort a
listen does that affect its ability to
interact with the toast plant so for
both of these strains the answer was yes
here we're looking at just infiltration
in this case the green bean pathogen and
green bean the black bar here is the
wild-type the gray bar here is heartfelt
deletion so this is blocked in its
ability to express the type 3 secretion
system and then all of these other
strains here BRMS bacteriocin resistant
these are all independent eye slits
independent mutations and we can see
that after 24 hours they really have a
growth defect except for this last 111
it has something of a growth defect that
seems to do better than the other
strains and that this growth defect does
persisted for EA shun 72 at least for
some of the strains I expect that this
is actually true for more of these
strains that there was just not enough
replicates here to get the statistics to
work and the same is true for path of
our glycemia so we can see again at 24
hours these strains are doing just about
as poorly as the harpell deletion mutant
does although they do significantly
better at 48 hours and 72 hours post
infiltration and again I think there's
some replication issue here that but
I've seen this multiple times with this
experiment multiple independent
experiments they always lag behind the
wild type string even at these later
time points okay so we know some of the
genetics underlying the bacteria some
production as well as what the
determinants for the sensitivity are and
so now we want to ask well does this
actually matter in an ecological sense
and so again going back to some of the
literature from the mid 60s so for
example a study here by Garrett and
colleagues where they were looking at
pseudomonads that they were taking off
of different fruit trees and this is a
little busy but I just want you to focus
on here when they looked at the bacteria
so that they were producing and the
majority of eye slits coming from pair
didn't kill other eye slits from pair
but they did kill ISIL it's coming from
citrus and the converse was also true
but the majority of strains isolated
from citrus don't kill other citrus eye
slits but do kill pair Iceland so I had
the opportunity to collaborate with
károly bulb and she was still out the
USDA in the Salinas Valley to ask some
more questions based on collections of
strange she had had so many people may
be familiar with the Salinas Valley it's
essentially the salad bowl of America
during the spring and summer growing
seasons before it shifts largely to
southern Arizona for the winter growing
in what she'd notice in this valley
there had been two different paths of
ours half of our API that would cause
leaf spot on celery and a different path
of our quarry and drink was it would
cause Lee spot-on salaam trance all
these had been known to occur within the
Salinas Valley and in the late 90s early
2000s there was this new disease that
emerged leaf spot of parsley so these
are all maybe AC family but the
interesting observation that she had is
that within the field or within a given
plan even though both of these paths of
ours existing are causing disease within
the valley she never found a mixed
infection so this would either be caused
by out of our API or a park ranger core
that she never found them co infecting
and so our question was well as this
potentially bacteriocin mediated
inhibition that's leading to this
difference so we screened a number of
API isolates and related strains and
compared those to the quarry and Rick
wise words and so now I'm just lumping
everything together i'm not showing
every I split individually but what I
want to draw your attention to is that
essentially all the API isolates killed
all the quarry in Jurek lies button so
this doesn't guarantee that this is why
there's this trade-off going in the
field but it's a strong indication it's
likely this is why you're only getting
one or the other infected even though
they're so confident and infecting this
host and so you know originally I
thought maybe there was going to be
reciprocal antagonisms but it turns out
that's likely not the case that it's
actually the path of our API if it
encounters the host first then it's
going to block or indirectly and Corrine
drikl is only going to infect in the
absence of API so of course there's work
that we're planning to do where we'll
get some resistant needs to Cory and
Ricola and then see it now we can get a
mixed infection and then conversely go
in and delete the bacteriocins out of
API and see if that also will allow for
the same co-infection to occur as well
and so that's ongoing work
so with that I would just like to
acknowledge my collaborators on this
work I postdoctoral adviser Dave altiris
as well a collaborator time runner who
really helped out with the molecular
phylogenetics for understanding the
evolution of the tailless in a bit the
derivation of the tail ism from
independent bacteriophages and then care
label again she is not moved to Penn
State and then I've had a number of
students that have worked with me and
contributed to the work that I've shown
and then of course I've gotten support
through the SQ service working so with
that be happy to take any questions
[Applause]
questions he's not here is it someone
else asked um boys miss U's car seat
oxygen do you see that there's like more
API cause like outbreaks yeah it's
seriously I'll competing the other no
that's a really good question and that's
something that I would really need to
talk to Carol II about because she has
that data I don't know if that's true
but that would be an expectation if its
inhibition in that way unless there was
some other compensatory thing that API
is not as good as remaining in certain
reservoirs or something like that there
may be some trade-off there but we would
expect that that's the only thing going
on the API may become the dominant one
yeah good question the question of leave
earlier in the talked you said that in
order for one of the blue monosomy Isis
resistance one bacterial so they must
swim trade-off and stability to a
different one and i was wondering if you
could explain why that might be or as if
are their genes are specifically being
trade to get it out at the same book is
it might cause that so sorry just to
reiterate you're asking for the
trade-offs and insensitivity between the
two what is the basis why is there that
trade-off yeah and the answer is I don't
know right now has a couple hypotheses
so
LPS is well known to serve a protective
function and so the idea maybe one of
the largest component of the outer
membrane and so potentially by losing
the LPS in its full structure there's
still the lipid a is going to be there
probably the coral ago saccharide may
still be there as well but it's lost all
of the o-antigen and the thought is
maybe there's some stress in the outer
membrane that's leading to upregulation
of an alternative cell surface receptor
that's all surface receptors are sort of
similar but different hypothesis because
that that receptor is always there but
the other bacteria some one of the
function of the LPS again we think about
it protecting against oxidative stress
antimicrobial peptides but it may also
be protecting this alternative receptor
from this other bacteria from being able
to access it and so there's a couple of
different questions but other than just
the loss of the for the disruption of
those LPS genes there shouldn't be
anything else different about those
strains complimenting them and showing
that it goes back I think would be
critical to shine that yeah but it's a
good question a quandary so what the
expression patent about the pro case
yeah yes you do for you please beaker
sawdust 50 with cards yeah no it's a
really interesting question when are
these when is this going to turned on
potentially within the plant environment
right that's where we would care about
so I do know that after infiltrating
fell into susceptible hosts and coming
back 24 hours I can recover the specific
coloring activity so they are getting
induced once at hand side I anticipate
that potentially certain stressors on
the leaf surface like UV exposure or
defecation stress or starvation will
also induce them so for all of mine
right I use mitomycin c it's sort of the
sledgehammer to get them to turn on all
of their SOS systems and produce all
these different compounds
the interesting thing about this is it
couldn't be constitutive because just
like with a virus it's too bulky to be
exported out of the cell and so there's
only a subset of the cells at any given
time that are going to express this
because they essentially lice to release
these into the environment at least
that's what our hypothesis based on all
the previous research that's been done
and so looking at the dynamics of
induction within the plant environment I
think is something I'm very keen on on
pursuing yeah good question a my
question against the producing strange
as it is with your tables and so if you
if you saw that it was all black boxes
on the diagonal there so there would
obviously be a high degree of selective
pressure to become resistant if you have
them sensitive so there's two things
related to that for the small like the
465 one that small single protein
bacteriocin we know that the producing
strain also has a characteristic
immunity protein associated with it for
the tail essence it's probably just that
it's LPS is not recognized by the tail
soon as it's produced but there's been
some work looking at evolution biofilms
and student on a syringe in elsa and you
will get these sweeps where a strain
will change itself yes to them suddenly
become sensitive and they can show it
starts to kill itself and so then it
quickly has another mutation that box
that from occurring so I think that does
crop up in nature let's quickly stamped
out make sure I understand so with your
initial screen you're using vitamin C
induces donors yeah to get extracts that
have been tested various lines and of
you mean do you get different patterns
of interaction if you look at a
competition release as opposed to this
licence fee fie fo now and that's
something that I definitely am
interested in looking at is
starting to move back into the plant
environment but we haven't looked at Co
competing them within Ellie's
environment to see how much it actually
matters because you may still just get
based on where you find them distributed
you may they may be able to coexist as
long as they're in different patches
that are isolated but over enough times
you know within a given field eventually
of interacting enough you might see it
sweep for one to the other but it's not
so good questions ok how many more
question this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu